having done one of these since the imc
ran things
could you hurry up and kill me before i
die of old age
morning fellas
don't be nervous
it won't help
margaret
it's mad maggie
you put that on my grape you're charged
with 27 counts of this edition
including 18 counts of inciting riots
against the syndicate alliance of free
worlds do you think zelda would riot if
they were free nine counts of raiding
syndicate transport ships ships that
were transporting salvonian supplies
away from salvoni and mouth
and of course
masterminding the cold-blooded attack on
the salvo syndicate merger ceremony
what's your deluded
self-justification for all that
bloodshed
freedom
this
is always a price
devastating
cowardly
and pointless
the treaty stein
salvo is a syndicate world now
silva was a free world
no matter whose flag you soil
which one of you gets to be the hero who
killed mad maggie ate
you
mate
i've been ready to die for salvo every
day since i was 12.
ready
mr silva says no
[Music]
i may be your judging jury but your own
friends will be your executioners you're
heading to the apex games
the outlands will watch you burn for
your price
bloody try to kill me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you